Ultra rare Aerodite W actually pointing out the obvious. Let's
go. Let's go. Hey, Destiny, if you if you believe Destiny is
is sincere when he comes to like finger wag at you about how
toxic your audience is, you are a
No, I don't say I never No, I I don't say I never read my chat.
I said on Lub and Learn when I'm going to engage with like four
or five other people, [__] gets through, you know,
a couple things get through and and I think that there are some
things that you described there that would be bannable 100%.
couple things. It's like half the chat. >> Okay. I mean,
show me specific uh things and I'll I'll go back to the VOD.
Um that's linked. I'll take a look at it. >> It's not about
going. It's not about going back. >> What is it about?
>> What should I do? Tell me what to do. >> Tell
me what Tell me the I want the prescription. One of those things
where if you have to say it, it doesn't it doesn't really matter.
It doesn't
>> It's like reminding a significant other about Valentine's
Day or something. It doesn't doesn't mean much. Or to say something
like, "Hey, could you compliment me right now because I need
words of affirmation?" You're like, "Oh, >> Uh it's not
his Discord this time. It's his like chats. Essay is relitigating
all of the same points he did before and he's going to end up
in the same place where he's not going to make a recommendation
cuz he is a whiny weepy. It doesn't really hit the same. It doesn't
work at that point. Right. If you don't have that
>> No, I I I don't want to make Hutch I don't want to make
Hutch uncomfortable. I have that desire. >> No, no. If
you don't have a desire for your chat to reflect the feelings
that you have to some extent towards other people, at least in
non-destructive ways, that just says a lot about, I guess, what
you're willing to put forward into the world. That's just a is
a very insane thing to me and it doesn't seem to be reflected
in almost any other streamer's chat that I'm aware of. Certainly
nobody in your sphere.
>> I mean, uh I don't know, dude. I I've we've had this
like moderation conversation internally and we've had stuff with
um with you and with um other people messaging me that we should
like immediately ban certain individuals or >> Why keep
jumping to that? Why do you keep saying that immediately ban
ban ban ban ban? >> The reason I go there is because I'm
trying to solve an issue. >> Is that the only thing you
know for how to moderate a community is is to ban people. That's
all you I'm I'm requesting more guidance from people who know
better, who claim to know better, like you. >> I think
that the way that you interact with people and I think that what
you allow in
>> I'm asking for a prescription from you. I think that
the way you interact with people shut the [__] up.
>> All right, we'll do we'll do all these clips. I'll just
do them all in a row. All in a nice row. So, here's the first
>> Weird disconnect for me between Pisco and the community
that he allows underneath him. And I don't know if he
It seems very strange to me like
I know that if I interact with Pisco, it will probably vastly
increase the harassment I experience for the next like week or
two um because of the amount of snark community members that
he allows in. And
it it's just very odd to me. I know that he's a big like free
speech person, but there's a certain amount of free speech that
has to go you don't like it feels like he goes like it feels
like his answer to this is so what? You want me to ban them?
It's like just time them out. Just be like, hey,
chill.
>> Yeah, hold on. But his answer to this is, "Give me a
prescription." It sounds like Arerodite has significantly more
testosterone and balls than Destiny does, cuz she said, "Oh,
well, you could time them out for like a week if they're going
to be mean to me." Like, at least she's going to say, and I believe
she'd probably reciprocate on that, right? She'd probably time
some people out for a week if they talk about somebody. She's
like, "Yeah, she's got no problem with mutual sweeping. That's
not a problem for her, right?" Like I she just gave a prescription.
Pisco's argument was what do you give me a rule so that I can
like evaluate it. Give me a rule that I can like put in a vacuum
and evaluate and we'll talk about it. And then people were like
no I don't want to give you a rule. That's the problem.
Dude, get out of here. Okay, that's funny. That's funny. Uh yeah,
I think she has no problem with mutual sweeping. She gave a rule.
I think the problem that I described earlier with Arerudite is
she sees chatters and she I think she has problems with things
she's done in the past where she's been wrong and never really
admitted it and she'll like basically have people who will bring
stuff up from her past and she hates that when she's been wrong
and she's like kind of gotten by it but then people will hold
her to those past opinions, past statements, past actions. She
despises that, right?
Really nothing else, nothing really upsets her more than that.
And so what she's really upset about here is the fact that there
are people in her community who are aware of her and aware of
her past and will bring stuff like that up.
That's and I I talked about a story from when I first started
streaming when she messaged me when she first joined my server
and was like, "Hey, just so you know, you've got like I can see
spicy chatters here. You've got like Rhox and Nyx Kao and Kuiman
and I just want you to know that they're like pretty crazy. They're
like I would have to go look at my logs to find the exact way
she phrased it." Okay. But it was basically that she they're
pretty crazy. And I'm like, "Okay, so do you want me to do something?"
She's like, "No, but you should keep an eye on it." And it's
like, "Okay." Like I You try to put these people on my radar.
It's like I'd already I already hung out in spicy chat. I already
knew exactly what was going on cuz I knew those people didn't
like her. I knew she didn't like them. And it wasn't like confusing
to me what she was trying to do.
Right. Imagine how embarrassing to go around. Well, I think like
I don't I don't actually disagree. I don't you guys don't make
money from this, okay? If you have like a business partner
and consistently
every time you you see these is like business relationships,
okay, and you have a business partner who you share a clientele
and whenever whenever you're watching the shared clientele
talk you and then the the influencer like allows that or even
agrees and like memes along. It does kind of feel like well they're
taking our shared clientele and making them like them more.
So, like there is there is like to me pretty obviously a reason
you wouldn't necessarily want this, right? I I again feel like
I'm like a little bit unique there in that I don't take super
offense to it. I guess it can be like bothersome, but as long
as you like have a it depends on your relationship with the other
person. I do get it. Okay. But Pisco Pisco is not her business
partner. Well, she's saying she would collab more. I think the
implication is she would collab more with Pisco if she felt like
this wouldn't happen to her, right? Is she feels like she wants
to peel away. I think the impression I get is she wants to pull
away from the Destiny adjacent stuff and do her own thing and
she doesn't want any of that stuff following her. She knows if
she engages with Pisco with like a bunch of chatters who would
know her past that that will get integrated into her new community
when she's trying to do this breakaway and that that's a problem.
So, I'm telling you that's probably what she's thinking right
now. Another way to describe that is she's done some bad things
and she doesn't want any of those bad things introduced to her
new community, right? That's that's like another way of looking
at that. If you didn't want that following her, she wouldn't
be saying this. She's hopping on the bandwagon. She is also hopping
on the bandwagon, which is annoying.
Sure, sure, sure, sure, sure, sure. Yeah, you might be right.
I'm I'm describing like a thing that I've I've felt like in a
vacuum
and like kind of had to think through how I want to address it,
right? So, I'm I'm describing to you my feelings is I think I
can deal with this. I could be okay with this depending on like
what I know about the other person and how evenly they apply
that lens. What what me off I think what pissed everybody off
about Destiny is that he doesn't let like if Destiny did what
Quman does like Queen is the example I'm literally thinking of
gets by his chat and he doesn't get mad at that or or moderate
that out. He lets that happen, right? He lets that happen to
him. The problem that Mr. Girl had with Destiny and a lot of
people have with Destiny specifically is that when Destiny gets
he'll mod that,
but he won't mod the same way for his friends or he wouldn't
for a long time,
So, it's like different when
if I went to his chat and said he's a defender, he wouldn't ban
me. I think you'd probably I feel like he'd offer for you to
hop in the Discord,
right? Probably.
Or maybe he just banned you. I do think it's like this thing.
I think that's like my experience. So as long as it's like you
you do it evenandedly
banned all mentions of his hidden support. Okay. Well, I this
is how I conceive of it. I'm just describing to you how I think
about it. Okay. There's another side to this which is she did
the same thing to me with regards to Destiny accusing me and
Queenman of like doxing and getting her swatted and right. There
was an implication that me and Quimman had done things that led
to her getting swatted and Erodite jumped on that bandwagon and
said, "Oh yeah, like I've been swatted."
It might have she might have even added swatting herself.
There was that implication. She totally jumped on that bandwagon
and like amplified it, right? And I feel like that same thing
is happening here to a lesser extent. Like it's a lesser crime,
but she's like doing a narrative amplification which I don't
like.
Right.
Yeah. I don't like it. Anyway, apparently she comments on this
stuff more as we go later. So, I wanted to get that clip in cuz
that is the first clip we watched earlier tonight. And I >> to
be honest, I don't think it's overly exciting. My take is is
essentially um >> there's so much astroturfing. It's amazing
that leftist Reddit threads read verbatim to Sean Hannity tweets.
>> To be honest, I don't think it's overly exciting. My
take is is essentially um
it's two things. Number one,
what do we mean when we say socialist? And more importantly,
what does the socialist mean when they call themselves a socialist?
Because when I'm talking about socialists that are outside of
my camp, I am talking specifically about people who probably
should be called communists, whether they're accelerationist
or not, who want to remove certain fundamental rights that I
think are essential to liberalism. One of the most common rights
that I think is a good litmus test for this is um
>> due process.
No due process for Howard Lutnik. No. No due process for Howard
ever. Okay. Sorry. I'm This one guy is actually like the entire
He's like the personification of every single scummy awful thing
that happens in Washington.
And like he's the guy where I'm like this guy has to go. If this
guy can't be prosecuted, nobody can. He's the guy who lied about
being on Epstein Island. They hid a picture of him on Epstein
Island from the files. Okay,
this stupid balding head.
He's got all this money from crypto. He started these crypto
things with Trump. He's he's I think one of the big people involved
in World Liberty Financial. Okay, [__] coward Lutnik
in every possible way. >> Property rights. If you are for
property
then you're probably going to be part of the tent. I don't think
regulation is socialism, right? Um, now socialists can and I
think rightly,
>> okay, so here's here's the thing now.
Regulation is not socialism.
So I want to nationalize an industry. I regulate that industry
out of existence and take their stuff at a at a like premium.
Have I violated their property rights? No. No. No. Let's just
say I tariff their industry super hard. Not even tariff. Let's
say I just tax their industry. I just create a new tax for their
industry.
Is that is that like that is the whole idea is could I in some
way democratically
decide to shut that industry down or nationalize it in some way?
Right? So you're like, "Oh, well, how would you take their property
if not by force? I bankrupt them. It would be coercive. It would
be very coercive, but it wouldn't be physical violence. It would
be financial coercion. Oh, financial coercion is wrong." Okay.
How do banks work? It's an agreement. Okay. I don't know. We
society gets to decide what the taxes are. If they're all in
agreement, then they get to do it. No, like there is something
illiberal there, but I don't I this is mostly me contending with
the regulation isn't isn't necessarily socialism or the regulation
doesn't count. Well, you could easily regulate an industry to
the point that it breaks. >> You do point out that increased
regulation is more socialistic and I would just totally grant
that. I think that that's totally fine. But when I'm talking
about socialism and a socialist, particularly the socialist that
is not part of the big tent, I'm >> so it's just it's like
thought termination, right? Well, I'm not talking about somebody
who wants regulation or something. I'm not talking about somebody
who wants to tax the wealthy. Well, it's like you could want
to tax the wealthy out of existence,
right? I don't know. It just feels like it was it's thought terminating
on I know Hassan's a tanky because of the drogram episode like
34 from 8 years ago where he said he hides his power level and
so so Hassan wants to take all property even violently and so
Hassan can't be a part of the 10. I'm talking about individuals
that actively would like to utilize and usurp the de democratic
process to bring about a a command economy ideally or would like
to remove private property, right? Whether they want to do it
violently or nonviolently. Obviously, they want to do it violently.
We all know those are tankies. Nobody's nobody's friends with
them any which is obviously a tanky. He just hides his power
level. And so there's this really big question. Okay, well what
about the socialists who still want private property? And I go
I think they're just like really progressive liberals. Like they're
not liberals. They're like progressive,
you know, social democrats or whatever, but they're still in
the liberal tent that I'm talking about when I mean liberal,
right? In that lower case L.
>> Okay. What incentive do we have that Hassan isn't one
of these progressives then? Like the people who want to slowly
adopt this to the point that there's no
>> And it seems like this isn't a hard line that can get
drawn. And the question actually is if for example, okay, they
>> okay. So she's talking about what leftists. So, she's
doing a stream called the state of the left and she's describing
what leftists can be included in the broad left tent cuz she
gets to decide that for one thing. Two, purity testing is the
worst thing you could do except when you're purity testing leftward.
And three,
um, Hassan is bad. I don't know. I don't know. I didn't >> first
one of their first hosts was a convoy. He does want to get rid
of his ideal version of politics would be the removal of private
property. So how should liberals and this is including even people
who want to regulate engage with people who want to get rid of
private property. That is their goal with within democracy so
but they want to get rid of private property rights. My argument
would be you need to work with them on like causes while fully
recognizing the whole time that they are not on your team. They're
in a different team and two teams can be allies. Two nations
can be allies but we are not the same group. And I think a really
big problem that's happened is that liberals really try to pretend
that they're socialists. um they try to be like, "Yeah, we're
just like you." And it's like, "Yeah, we have like 98% overlap,
but the issue is the 2% where we differ is really, really, really,
really important fundamentally." So, >> okay, so she never
mind. I I will pull this back. I believe now she's saying I thought
she was going to say econo boy would be fine. I believe she's
saying econo boy out of the coalition, right? I cannot be in
a coalition with econo boy. So anyway, I it sounds like she's
saying economy would be out of the coalition
They try to want to get rid of private property. is their goal
with within democracy still, but they want to get rid of private
property rights. My argument would be you need to work with them
on like causes while fully recognizing the whole time that they
are not on your team. They're in a different team and two teams
can be allies. Two nations can be allies, but we are not the
same group. And I think a really big problem that's happened
is that liberals really try to pretend that they're socialists.
Um they try to be like, "Yeah, we're just like you." And it's
like, "Yeah, we have like 98% overlap, but the issue is the 2%
where we differ is really, really, really, really important."
fundamentally so right and this is something that I think leftists
actually say a lot is being like I don't care that we agree about
98% if we disagree about the 2% but the 2% is fundamental to
my world view then no we don't agree which is true this is a
good point by the by the leftist and I think it's been gross
that liberals in the past have really tried to be like you're
just like us you're just like it's like no they're not if they
want to get rid of private property rights no they're not if
they want to at a state level mandate a democratized workplace
no they're not they're something else we can still work with
them. We can be friends with them and friends with many communists,
but they're not under the same political tent because their end
goals are fundamentally different. >> I actually am not
sure that that's different at all. And I'm not sure you could
even justify this. Like you could shift towards like a a sovereign
wealth fund. You could slowly start nationalizing industry purely
as like a capitalistic practice,
you could apply pressures and like I I think they like technically
the end goal could be something like no private property but
I don't think econo boy has that thought. I don't I don't know
if economy's described like no private property is a thing that
he needs to do. I think he just believes that the state has slowly
become more and more capable of taking on things like that and
that having the state be in charge of that might prevent you
know private property from getting totally crazy. Most left-leaning
liberals aren't committed to private property. They just think
capitalism has produced good results. Yeah. Like I just don't
I don't see where the problem is where it's like anti-liberal
to not have private property
um like in in some ways or to reduce the amount of places that
you could privatize ownership of things,
right? Like I'm not saying you can't have private property anywhere,
but certainly like let's say you know you want to nationalize
an industry, you want to work towards that. I don't see how that's
Yeah. I don't know. and having like an end goal for that. I think
a lot of people like econ boy would probably admit that he doesn't
think he'd ever get to the end goal of like totally abolishing
private property. It's that I think the state can do more to
ensure the wellness of their people by making sure that they
have a stake in the like capital ownership of their country.
Right. Right. >> Be honest, I don't think it's overly
tent because their end goals are fundamentally different. be
honest. I don't think it's overly
>> What the
Why?
Okay. All right. Okay. All right. All right. Okay. All right.
We've got We've got more. We've got one more on the live and
learn stuff. So, she's talking about the live and learn stuff
with people. Okay. Here we go. This is the next one. >> That's
it. >> I will say I've only been on live and learn once.
Their chat was really really vitriolic. They were really negative.
Um they could be really really nasty and I was very surprised.
>> who did she get into it with? Was it a Conno boy that
she started arguing with? I'm trying to think. I think it was
a Connor boy she started arguing with, right? Like she started
arguing very
while chatgptting things to argue with him. So I I don't know.
It could be that they picked up something like that. Maybe maybe
I don't know. >> It's very strange to be like personally
friends with people and then to watch them allow their chat to
treat and talk about you in such a way. Um because in some to
some degree that means that they're kind of complicit in what's
being said about you. Um and it's tough because especially in
liberal spaces you don't get to tell people
how to act or how to manage their community.
Well, it's not even libs. That's the problem. Most of the most
like vitriolic people are all the like psychotic socialists.
And the issue is like why is Lib and Learn
attracting and maintaining so many socialists especially like
the vitriolic ones like them allow
to treat
>> I why are you assuming they're
>> and talk about you in such a way um because in some
to some degree that means that they're kind of complicit in what's
being said about you. Um and it's tough because especially in
liberal spaces you don't get to tell people
how to act or how to manage their community.
Well, it's not even libs. That's the problem. Most of the most
like vitriolic people are all the like psychotic socialists.
And the issue is like why is lib and learn
attracting and maintaining so many socialists, especially like
the vitriolic ones. Like why why are they there? You don't want
them. I'm assuming
it's definitely
explicitly said he wants them. Pisco has explicitly said he loves
people who are like out outside the box that he can argue with.
He wants those people around. Pisco has literally said that multiple
times in his community that he wants those people that it's not
I Bro,
if you want four people who have the exact same opinion that
the Democrats are always right, the Democrats are always winning,
they're always the best forever, just go watch Iris stream,
right? You want all that alignment, you want all the the blue
no matter who only liberal only like the mainstream liberal takes,
you can just go watch IRI. What the is the point of having a
panel of people with the exact same beliefs?
I literally don't get it. >> Definitely what we don't want
shaping like the liberal social space. >> What would be
it would be so much less shameless if these people weren't just
explicitly getting ass mad that people talk about them. If they
really had a committed principle in this way that like, oh, I
just don't like people who who believe in tanky stuff. You don't.
You literally highlight all the time that it's because they're
vitriolic, because they're mean.
You just don't like mean people. You just don't want people to
be mean to you. But you introduce the politics because you don't
want them to be mean to you. But you don't want to just say that.
Just say, "Please ban people who are mean to me." That's all
you got to do. Stop
grabbing other things to introduce them to make it about anything
else. I don't want people who bring up the fact that Rose was
17 in my community, in your community either. Okay? Please stop
bringing up Please stop bringing up the fact that Rose was 17.
It's like, okay, just ask for that. Just say that and say nothing
else. Don't talk about tankies. Don't talk about starkers. Just
say, I don't like when people bring up my like indiscretions.
I think that should be banned from your chat. Literally, just
say the thing that you're actually mad about, right, for Destiny
or for Ardite. I don't like, she might say, I don't like when
people make jokes about the whistleblower thing. It's like, okay,
then just say that. I don't like when people say I sweat for
Destiny. Then just say that.
Don't make it about politics. Don't make it about socialists.
You people are so fragile. It's obvious you're reaching for the
political thing because you just don't like the personal thing.
>> No, no, it's not live and learn. It's peace chat specifically.
I know. I know P people have said it's specifically Pisco chat,
which um I can't comment to one way or the other. I'm not totally
sure cuz I didn't go and investigate it myself. Um I just know
that there's a number of community members in his community that
are
uh awful at least towards me and it sounds like towards other
people as >> Holy. Let's see. >> I will say I've
only been on Living Land once. Their chat was really really v.
>> Okay. Okay. Okay. We're at the end of the stream. At
the end of this
Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. We're fine. We're fine. We're fine.
We're fine. We're fine. We're fine. We're fine. Okay. Another
clip. >> I don't know that I would. >> So, apparently,
um, she comments on the Destiny being the person to go after
>> and I also don't think that Steven should be the one
having this conversation with Pisco. I don't blame Pisco for
not being at all receptive to it coming from Steven particularly
because like uh Steven has been very critical of Pisco. I would
argue that he has not clamped down on his audience AS AN ULTRA
RARE AERODYITE W actually pointing out the obvious. Let's go.
Let's go.
Hey Destiny, if you if you believe Destiny is is sincere when
he comes to like finger wag at you about how toxic your audience
is, you are a
okay. And Pisco made that clear in his stream that he didn't
believe it. He's like, "Obviously this is insincere. Obviously
this is just malicious lies, but I'm going to like once Hutch
says, well, actually I do have a problem with it." Then he's
going to take care of it. >> Engagement with Peace Go nearly
sufficiently um because he's mad at him. I'm sure he'll be hot
and mad. Again, if somebody says, "Where are your receipts?"
I don't have them. This has been my perception as somebody who
is not overly involved in any of this drama, but likes both of
these individuals, which is that the two people who should least
be talking about moderation of the community together, not because
it's not an important topic, and not because either of them have
a good insight, is going to be Steven and Pisco. And I would
not blame Pisco for not receiving it well from Steven. Why the
would he? Right. The only people who I think are more reasonable
to talk to Pisco about moderation if they have issues with it
is Hutch. Hutch brings up. Yeah. And Hutch is a good person to
talk to him about it. Right. And if he's resistant with Hutch,
I'm not I'm not saying that Pisco doesn't be resistant. I don't
know. I would watch this conversation with Hutch. I'm just saying
people being like he should receiving it from Steven. It's like
that's a pretty like big tall ask of like being like you should
receive it from somebody who like you used to be friends with,
you had a huge fallout and like you feel very angry at and don't
have a close relationship with anymore. It's like no, but you
should try to receive it from
>> Well, hold on. Oh, I hate that. That you feel very angry
at.
Why does he feel angry? Why would if Pisco were to feel angry,
why would he feel angry?
Can we Can we talk about that? I would love that conversation.
I hope somebody asks. Wait, why do you think Pisco is angry?
I didn't watch this stream. If anybody did, could you tell me
if she if she asked or if anybody asked her cuz that would be
very interesting for me to know. Why do you think Pisco is angry
at Destiny?
What happened? Cuz I think personally it's Destiny's implication
repeatedly that he's a tanky. Destiny's mischaracterizations
of his positions. When Pisco calls him out on those mischaracterizations,
Destiny's refusal, even though admitting, even though he'll admit
he was wrong, he will not apologize for mischaracterizing him,
right?
All of this stuff has happened. Uh, beyond that, Pisco spent
a bunch of his time, professional and and literal capital to
build a set in New York so that Destiny could come and interview
DNC like I think chair race people like for the people who were
in the race for the DNC chairship, chairmanship, whatever you
would call it, right? They wanted to be chair of the DNC.
And then Destiny wasn't I believe Destiny likely wasn't totally
forward or totally honest about exactly what had happened with
the Pixie situation, those leaks. Right.
Right. I think I think that's what happened is Pisco was setting
all this stuff up. He had these commitments and then probably
Destiny wasn't totally forthcoming about exactly what was going
to come out and then Pisco was caught off guard is my guess.
I don't know for sure. It's my guess from Hutch. The issue is
does Hutch make specific prescriptions? Does he make specific
prescriptions or not? And if he does like if Hutch says can you
time people out and Pisco says no. Uh I would love to see it.
People can send me the clips of that. But if he was receptive
and Hutch just doesn't make any specific asks, while I would
argue probably Pisco could figure out the asks that should be
implied from this, >> god damn it, >> should also
make explicit asks.
>> I feel like this is a test of me specifically cuz she's
just copying my exact position on all of this,
>> right? She's copying my exact position. I feel like
this is a test. Will I snark her when she agrees with me 100%.
She's just going to agree with my opinion totally on the Hutch
Pisco thing.
I feel like she watched my coverage. She's going to copy the
position one to one and see is this guy good? Is this guy still
gonna No, it's obviously correct. I said all of this
>> but also I would argue
Pisco does like no matter what Pisco does have to think about
the fact that there is the c the community that's cultivated
around him in such a way like he does need to go why the [__]
is this the community that's formed around me? Why is that happening?
Why do people think that it's okay to come into my community
and snark about my own friends? Like why would they think that
I would be tolerant of that? And if I am tolerant of that, why
am I tolerant of that? and how does that impact my friends?
But remember, >> I you can really break a lot of this down
to the actual like the actual Pixie lawsuit and the way Destiny's
behaved after the fact and the communities that don't feel comfortable
being in Destiny's community but would feel comfortable being
in Pisco's community and how they would feel about anybody who
is not like overtly disgusted by Destiny's behavior.
Right? Is that not almost the entire we not just with that one
piece of information explained the entire gap and how we think
these has nothing to do with politics. It has everything to do
with hey there's a guy who will do political content who is not
like a predator in any way and so we actually want to watch that
guy and we don't like the people who sweep for destiny and there's
some Israel Palestine there's some other things that mix in there
but I feel like that is way more explanatory of people's opinions
than anything else.
It's why Josiah doesn't get anywhere near as much heat. Josiah
just [__] off. It's why Hutch gets heat when he continues
to do like the I'm not a Destiny orbiter, but I'm going to watch
all of his content and constantly interact with his community
bed. Like, right. It's it explains it to me. It explains all
of the different levels of anger for all the different people.
And by the way, I don't even agree with some of the levels of
anger. Like the litterbox stuff I don't agree with,
But it it does explain all of it. And that's to me why they bring
up the politics. It's why they bring up all of these adjacent
arguments. Snarkers, snarkers, snarkers. That's the problem ultimately
is what it boils what it boils down to is they don't like that
people in Piscos community don't like Destiny.
They want those people to not be welcome.
Guess what? There are very valid, very honest, very, very,
I would say, undeniable,
inarguable reasons to dislike Destiny that don't apply to Pisco.
It's that's we've literally explained it. You've you explained
it for me. You explained it for a bunch of the people I know
who watch both or who used to watch Destiny and watch me and
also watch Peace Go. Like that explains it, right? Sure. Destiny
has a notorious history as well of like he moderates his community
a ton, but he also allows his community to like rag on people
and his community is particularly just very negative a lot of
the time. Like I have a hard time being around and spending time
with DG because they're just they're also emotionally distant
fathers. They're very quick to criticism and very slow to compliments.
Um which makes sense. I think Steven is also this type of personality,
but that necessarily makes a community like that which makes
the community very harsh, very critical, often very pointed and
they're like ptorians of of chatters, okay? Their criticism are
very harsh and they're slow to compliments and I think that that's
not great either and that can be really really daunting and that's
what's led to a whole bunch of dramas for Destiny in in moderation
in the past. Um, I don't think that there's a perfect easy solution,
but there is a question where you go, what am I? Now, I will
say I will say that probably gives you an indication of just
how correct I was with this precise argument
that even Arerodite despite all of the reasons to disagree with
me and to agree with Destiny and to to sweep for Destiny. Despite
all of this stuff,
she still has to she has to agree with me, she has to make the
same points because it is so transparently obvious that Destiny
has not done this for his friends when they've asked for it specifically
in the past. And now he is somehow like wagging his finger at
Pisco trying to tell Pisco how to moderate his chat and it's
embarrassing. >> What am I doing that contributes to the
the the state of the >> Yes, I am just sucking myself off.
>> Just so you know. Yes, I am. Yes, I am just saying I
was right the whole time. >> Okay, apparently ogre boy
comes into the chat. Ogre boy comes into the chat. The >> to
the analogy. >> The analogy doesn't work. Gavin is a tourniquet.
If improperly applied, you'd lose a limb and the patient can
still eventually die. I have you blocked everywhere. So, I don't
feel like I want to engage with you because you're such a nasty
person. But
>> that's actually the opposite of the truth. Ogre Boy
is really not a na who even thinks I don't think anybody thinks
Ogre boy is a nasty person.
I don't think that's not even a criticism of Ogre Boy,
bro. What? I think you're such a nasty person. Who said that?
I've never seen Ogre Boy do one of the like I've never seen Ogre
Boy do one of these things where he's like, "Oh, Lunarbox likes
watching kids die or something." He's never done that, right?
>> It's a good argument.
Oh. Oh. Oh. Do I take the Do I take the bite because it's a good
argument or do I just ban you because I have you banned everywhere
else? I have two wolves.
>> Hasn't he used mean words to hutch on Twitter? So, I
would like to see Hold on. We go what? From Ogre Boy or something
here. From Ogre Boy 6. And then we say
to not so arerodite. Does this work? Does this notation work?
Hold on. Let me let me try the advanced search. To not so aerodite.
I want to see if if ogre boy has ever said anything to her on
Twitter. From ogre boy 6.
No.
Does not appear that ogre boy ever said anything to Aerodite
on Twitter. So what did he get blocked for?
Wouldn't this get replies to? Hold on. Latest. No.
No. I I wonder why she'd have him blocked on Twitter.
Weird, weird, weird. Okay, we keep >> We don't keep watching
there. We keep watching here. >> The tool is inside of
me. >> And one of them,
one of them is an ogre.
Not blocked. Muted. Oh, okay. Wait, can you see if people mute
you?
I think if you block people, it mutes them. I You can't tag me.
Get him banned. But we do have to engage with this argument.
Which wolf will you feed? In the analogy, Gavin is a tourniquet.
What I'll do is I'll engage with it, but I'm also going to ban
you from my chat. Um, cuz you've like had a history of being
genuinely awful towards me. So, let's get [__] What
did you do to her, Ogre boy? Where's Ogre boy? What did you do
to her, Ogre boy? What did you do? What did Ogre Boy do to Natu
Aerodite? What did he do that was so mean, so evil to not
I don't know what Ogre Boy has said, so I can't really say.
He's streaming, but could jump on. Um,
yeah, maybe I'll just I wouldn't I'll I'll keep it, By the way,
I'll keep it like chill. All right, I won't go crazy on Ardite
cuz I don't want Ogre Boy to get in trouble. I'll drag him on
if he if he wants to talk. If he's not doing something, if he's
doing something and he's like busy, it's fine, too. But I wouldn't
mind going through this clip with him and just asking like, "What
did he do?
What did you do to Arrodite? Man, what the [__] did
you do?
You're like super mean."
Okay. Okay. Okay. All right. What is this? You put Anna onto
this. >> This is a
>> uh But you can't do it with her. You You got to You
got to ret transform the voice into her voice or something. It
doesn't work. >> This is what WE LOOK LIKE. THIS IS WHAT
WE ACT LIKE. THIS IS WHAT EVERYBODY WAS like before us. This
is what I am. I'M A THROWBACK. I'M HERE. I'VE GOT THE FIRE OF
LIBERTY. I'M SETTING FIRES EVERYWHERE and are turning on everywhere.
>> Okay. All right. All right. I I think I just tweeted
it before the stream. >> THIS IS WHAT WE LOOK LIKE. THIS
IS WHAT WE ACT LIKE. THIS IS WHAT EVERYBODY WAS like before us.
This is what I am. I'M A THROWBACK. I'M HERE. I'VE GOT THE FIRE
OF LIBERTY. I'M SETTING FIRES EVERYWHERE. And are turning on
everywhere. This is a This is what >> Ogre boy. Hello.
Welcome to the stream. How's it going? Muted.
>> Currently muted. True. >> Uh can you turn your
Oh, you can't hear your mic on. Perfect. What you what you didn't
hear me say was a nervous chuckle and then a hey, what's up?
What's going
>> Oh, I was I was watching this airite stream and she
banned you earlier tonight
and she said you're like a terrible person. So, I was just curious
what she'd said to her. I was just going to ask you like what
did you say? >> I had been told that.
>> Uh I happened upon her stream at a mo moment when she
was hyping Gavin Newsome. She was making a
analogy that uh the libs are trying to save the patient that
is America.
She said that the America is bleeding out. It's bleeding out
and you know the libs are straddling the patient trying to put
on a tourniquet trying to stop the bleeding and the lefties are
being spoiled brats and um standing in the way of that and we're
being like and she's she's making this analogy about like first
aid and from the chat I basically just went hey that analogy
doesn't work because if anything Gavin Newsome's a tourniquet
and if you don't apply a tourniquet appropriately and remove
it appropriately you can cause like mass massive hemorrhaging
and you can even lose the p you can eventually lose the patient
again and or maybe even lose a limb. And I said and and the idea
was is if I would have had that chance to flesh that out, I would
have put like that's what the quote unquote the lefties are concerned
about is that you know Newsome gets into office. He's only there
for four years. He doesn't really deliver anything. He doesn't
clue like the voting public in on what the uh you know the shortcomings
are. people unplug four years from now and then like super turbo
Hitler on the Republican tick get gets in in like 2032. That's
the actual at least to me at least that's the the lefty argument.
Um she just heard my my statement about the tourniquet and she's
like hm >> that's a good point but also you're a terrible
person. >> We watched the clip, right? We watched the clip.
To be clear, I wasn't asking about I I knew what the analogy
was and all that. We we did go over the clip. I >> we went
over a clip of it. What I what I wanted to ask you is she says,
"Oh, I'm gonna answer you, but I'm gonna ban you because you've
been a terrible person to me and you are a really terrible person
in general." You say >> I don't even [__] remember.
The last time I tried to say her on Twitter was like months and
months and months ago.
>> yeah. But I I'm Does she have you
>> Um I didn't think so. I thought she muted me a long
time ago. Give me just a >> cuz Yeah. I was just curious.
She say awful. tried to get into her Discord.
I would have tried to get it. No, I'm not
Actually, here. I mean,
yeah, I'm not blocked at all. I'm muted. So, so just
I I have it over on my stream right now.
>> Uh because she never responds. And I think at one point
she was having a conversation with like Wick like over a year
ago or something like that and basically showing that um thing
like that. Oh, that's a nasty little person. And I just mute
them and move on essentially. But like, yeah, I'm not I'm not
blocked.
>> so if she never responds, that means >> Huh? That's
Rio Ripley. Never mind. >> What? What's the issue? >> Fair
enough.
>> I don't know. I have done that before. >> Quick.
You're on kick for God's sake.
>> Well, no. I was just saying I usually don't do this
kind of thing outside of like one
>> one specific time where I've done it. I usually don't
do it.
Well, >> no. I mean, I hear you. Some things are very important,
especially Where's the >> Dude, if you're going to put
that on the screen, at least plug your [__] Twitter
group. What happened? What
>> What do you mean?
>> Oh, I had one of those. That was
>> No, but if you're going to put that up at all, you got
to It's marketing, man.
Anyway, yeah, I have no [__] >> I'm not going
to take her, put my marketing on it. That'd be crazy.
>> no, but you did. Did you or did you not? Yes or no?
Did you or did you not have one that was sell advertising the
Twitter group?
>> No, I don't think so.
>> Unless I was maybe just doing it with words. I don't
think I did it advertising the Twitter group ever.
>> Um
Okay. I maybe I just misremember the bit, but um >> that's
neither here nor there. Yeah. So, I'm not blocked. I don't remember
what the last thing I said was. Um she never responds to anything
that I did put. So, I just stopped giving a at a certain point.
I just saw that she was streaming. I was listening in for a little
bit. She was doing like some like you already saw she was doing
like Gavin Newsome apologia and trying to hype him up and I'm
like you're you're just you're fundamentally medically wrong.
Like it's not even a good analogy. And then that just took all
the wind out of her sales and she's like I'm going to ban you
but I should at least answer. And then she even got the followup
thing wrong. Like a tourniquet doesn't have anything to do with
sep. That's [__]
stupid. Anyway,
>> okay. you're cutting out a little bit, but I I heard
the gist of it. Um, so I
>> yeah, I just I I feel like I'm not even sure that Hutch
of all people says you're like an awful person or you say awful
things. I feel like he finds you annoying, but I feel like that's
not your reputation to go and say like crazy like there is a
reputation for some chatters that will go and say like Kathy
or something will go and say crazy in people's chats, right?
But that's not your reputation. Like you're not a person who
goes and like talks about watching like loving watching kids
die or something. >> Anyway, go ahead. >> No, I generally
don't do that. I I when when the I think there was like a rumor
or something that she went with Brianna Woo to Israel or that
they both went like around the same time >> or something
along those lines and then she started going really heavy in
the paint with her like Twitter posts. >> I'm I'm trying
to be as fair as possible. Um, but there was there was a time
when she was like heavy timeline posting about like the you know
the people in Gaza this and Israel that and so on and so forth
that I may have said some some critical some hyper critical [__]
but I don't think I was ever like you just want to see like dead
babies or something because that's not that's not my style at
all. So
>> that's weird. So I didn't even see that. I I tried searching
for it. I couldn't find anything like that. Have you done like
a Twitter wipe or something?
For the longest time I was every seven days, but I stopped doing
that like a month or two ago.
>> Okay. So that those tweets would be gone then if those
tweets did exist. >> Yeah. And like I said, I stopped giving
a like middle of last yearish. So her her like I've definitely
blocked you. It's like no, I just didn't care anymore. There's
a difference.
>> I see. Okay. Interesting. I was just curious. Yeah,
cuz I'm I'm like I hate I feel like she's done that to me and
other people. She'll just she'll like hear something from a different
source and she'll like totally repeat it or amplify it without
really considering and it's very frustrating. >> I was
very
>> I was very serious about like I was going to join her
Discord right after that but I had a pizza on the way and I didn't
give a [__] So, but um
>> All right. Cool. I just want to ask about that. Thanks.
>> Yeah. Boy 6 on Twitch, guys. He's live right now if
you ever want to check him out. Okay. We'll see you later.